é nós somos os danos do produto
significa que o nosso dia a dia a gente
dizem é projetos pra empresas pequenas
etapas empresas familiares até
multinacionais ea gente desenvolve são
bens de consumo que são produzidos em
massa
a gente tem uma obsessão assim o
significado das coisas e pensar o que
são bens de consumo né
eles realmente fazem o bem e se eles
fazem o bem eles fazem pra quem milhares
de empreendedores da indústria
todo mundo tem uma parcela nessa
responsabilidade e por outro lado é que
justamente a gente que pode transformar
isso a gente pode transformar essa
realidade vai mostrar hoje pra vocês
compartilhar dois projetos nossos eles
são bem diferentes é um do outro mas o
mais importante não são os produtos em
si mas o porquê a gente acabou criando
eles o significado por trás de cada um
deles
o motivo da existência é a do design
como uma ferramenta que serve para dar
voz à causa como por exemplo uma pessoa
quando sofre uma amputação ela perde o
volume
membro e ela também pede muito da
autoestima dela
a gente conheceu várias conversou com
várias ea gente viu que elas começaram a
falar que elas nem se reconhecer mais
quando eu vejo vocês devem se lembrar da
última vez que viram usando uma prótese
de perna por exemplo a pessoa fica com
com esse plugin metálico e que não é um
pouco estranho eles mesmos falam que é
esquisito chama a atenção por conta
disso eles acabam tentando se esconder
de alguma forma seja com de fé neles mas
acabam se isolando de algumas maneiras
de se sentirem confortáveis com isso
confortáveis também com um
a relação que as pessoas têm no dia a
dia existem algumas opções que tem
tentado mudar isso que tenta devolver o
volume da perna
por exemplo uma espuma que imita o
formato da pele coloca uma meia calça
por cima para tentar limpar a pele custa
mais ou menos 1.200 reais
tem também outras opções são mais
descoladas em diferentes zonas
geralmente feitas geralmente feita por
impressão 3d das principais marcas
globais chegam no brasil uma média de
quatro mil reais para pensar os países
que mais têm pessoas com imputação no
mundo
além dos estados unidos os outros três
são brasil em destino justamente países
em desenvolvimento onde produtos como
esses são totalmente inacessíveis
justamente para a maior parte das
pessoas que mais precisam
a gente queria entender então por que
raios que um produto que é aparentemente
é tão simples porque raios ele é tão
caro a gente foi indo atrás saindo atrás
descobri o que era feito até então era
feito tudo sob medida era feito um é
como se precisasse usar qualquer peça de
roupa desde que chama um terno objetivo
qualquer coisa eu se fosse por um
alfaiate que existia um sistema de
alfaiataria porque é totalmente inviável
para grande parte da população
a gente descobriu então que era possível
a gente inventar a camiseta tamanho m
das capas de prótese de perna
a gente encontrou os nesse pedacinho de
papel tão simples tão pequenininho a
simbologia
para guiar esse nosso projeto isso é um
confete é um confete é colorido e leve
ele serve pra homem para a mulher para
novo pra velho pra rico para pobre
ele é super democrático e as pessoas só
usam ele no momento de alegria
assim surgiu a confete a confete ela é a
primeira capa de prótese de perna
produzido em massa no mundo é muito
louco para pensar que ninguém parado
para pensar nisso aí é a confete é uma
capa que ela é super ajustável então ela
tende a grande maioria dos amputados
dessa forma a gente conseguiu tornar ela
é extremamente acessível
ela tem esses furos lembrou slide ele
nos confetes jogados para cima quando se
forma aquelas elipses esses furos além
da a capa mais leve
ele também torna possível de customizar
essas capas então amputado pode deixar
ela com a personalidade dele e expressar
a quem ele é e como ele é e ter orgulho
disso
produzido em massa a gente conseguiu
fazer com que ela ficasse até 80% mais
barato do que as outras opções que
existem hoje
isso quer dizer que ela é a opção mais
acessível dos 19 países em que está
presente hoje no brasil ela também está
disponível gratuitamente para quem mais
precisa pelo sus o inss
a gente quis fazer isso dessa maneira
porque pra gente o ponto de partida de
qualquer projeto que a gente vai fazer
não é o produto em si mas o que a gente
está trazendo para o mundo com isso
queria de fato trazer para a vida das
pessoas com isso e nesse caso de
perceber desde o princípio que não era
sobre o produto não era sobre uma capa
de próximo do que a gente entregar a
autoestima
a gente quis transformar em uma coisa
mais acessível possível para poder
beneficiar de alcançar um maior número
de pessoas é incrível ver quando a gente
acessa por exemplo as redes sociais
a gente vê não conversam tantas
publicações tantas fotos de pessoas
computação publicaram de mostrar as suas
pernas
e parece tão simples vezes significa
bastante coisa a gente ver histórias de
pessoas que voltaram a ir pra praia
confortavelmente voltar a usar bermuda
ea gente ouve relatos que as pessoas
continuam se aproximando mas não mais
pra mim perguntar o que aconteceu e não
mais para perguntar o que aconteceu no
dia da palestra é um momento da vida mas
sempre apontar e falar que massa só
perna percebe é outra aproximação uma
freqüência muito mais positiva é uma
mudança na percepção da sociedade
acredita que a real inovação é
exatamente isso a real inovação
ela consiste numa mudança de pensamento
para um bem maior potência ou não está
associado a uma tecnologia de ponta
a gente vê muita gente é tentando achar
que inovação e tecnologia são duas
coisas que não se separam uma da outra o
que não é verdade
no caso da confete a gente deu passos
para trás e usando uma tecnologia que já
existe há décadas enquanto as outras
pessoas no mundo estão fazendo isso
através da impressão 3d
a gente usou uma técnica um processo de
fabricação super acessível para ele ser
produzido em escala e dessa forma a
gente conseguiu tornar o produto é
adaptável para a maioria das pessoas e a
gente mudou se tornou uma coisa
realmente executiva dentro da indústria
uma coisa que realmente deu alguns
passos para trás pra gente poder olhar
realmente pra frente vai ter um olhar um
pouco mais humano
a gente acredita que para a sociedade
receber todos os benefícios que são
funcionais é poéticos inclusivos que o
design eo empreendedorismo tem a
oferecer
a gente precisa principalmente no brasil
e permite usar essa percepção que as
pessoas têm de design e empreendedorismo
só assim a gente consegue tornar
projetos cada vez mais inclusivos e não
exclusivos por exemplo é o material é
muito usado no mundo inteiro
é maravilhoso é gostoso tem um toque
moça bonita é super durável é
superversátil atrasar em várias coisas e
há milhares de anos a humanidade já faz
esse processo de transformar de fazer o
coro com pele de animais
nesse processo de transformar a pele em
couro se chama curtição e curtição é um
processo em dois curtos
pouca gente sabe mas os principais
portões no brasil hoje ele tem um
rigoroso controle ambiental e como todas
essas pedras são provenientes da
indústria do descarte da indústria
notícia acaba que o couro é muito menos
nocivos para o ambiente quando comparado
por exemplo com esses cursos ecológicos
ecológico na verdade um nome muito
errado nome chique quiseram dar para um
tecido e é na verdade feita à base de
petróleo
então tenho uma coisa a gente começou a
pensar assim
se você for analisar o processo inteiro
e produção do couro
antes dele chegaram os curtumes ele
envolve muitas vezes desmatamento e
envolve principalmente muita emissão de
dióxido de carbono na atmosfera é um dos
principais vilões no efeito estufa e sim
então ao invés desse processo que
antecede a competição ao invés de você
está emitindo co2 no meio ambiente
imagina que louco seria se você pudesse
retirar co2 da atmosfera se pudesse
realmente limpar o ar parece uma ideia
muito muito muito maluca mas a natureza
já faz isso há milhares e milhares de
anos e depois de quatro anos de estudo
surgiu de um curtume que fica na
floresta tropical brasileira surgiu o
primeiro eo tecido feito à base de
folhas do mundo
o tecido é nada mais nada menos do que o
processo que você curtir a folha
isso resulta no material e ele é em
propriedades é muito parecido com o
couro bovino campo e resistência como um
toque tem um visual muito mais legal mas
a
ao ponto dele é que o processo inteiro
se você for analisar de crescimento da
planta até a curtição ele acaba
retirando mais co2 na atmosfera do que o
limite no processo inteiro
então esse é um material que é carbono
positivo e você produzir coisas com esse
material
você acaba de pando o planeta como o
mundo do design dos móveis têm uma
visibilidade muito grande a gente criou
a primeira coleção de produtos feitos
com esse de tecido de fora justamente
pra colocar um holofote em cima disso
nesse material para chamar a atenção
para isso é uma solução que une o melhor
da sabedoria ancestral natureza com a
criatividade humana
então a gente fica imaginando quando
isso tiver espalhado pelo mundo inteiro
aplicado em tudo que é produto objetos
bens de consumo desde os mais banais até
as coisas mais complexas porque no mundo
inteiro e até fora dele a gente quer
dizer o interior de uma estação espacial
com isso a gente imagina que o futuro é
ao contrário do que muita gente pensa
não é frio
ele não é estéreo digno das utopias de
ficções científicas
a gente acredita que o futuro que a
gente quer
ele está num livre desmo que abraça as
diversidades e em aprimora o melhor de
diferentes mundos é o futuro que ele é
respeitar o passado
respeito o futuro o tradicional e um
super tecnológico ou natural e o digital
é uma fusão disso tudo e não na
polarização das coisas têm acontecido
tanto hoje a gente acredita que o futuro
ele está no diálogo
a gente acredita profundamente que a
gente pode desviar desse caminho a
seguir hoje para investir muito mais
bela agente juntos
somente juntos a gente consegue criar e
transformar essa realidade pôde ver em
breve
a gente gostaria de treinar com um
convite à a todos/as criar o bem mas e
criar esse bem em larga escala
obrigado